where do you think parenting is going to  shift what do you think the secret's  going to be for this next generation i  think that we need to get out of our  kids [ __ ] because when i was a kid and  definitely everybody older than me you  kind of had to figure out your [ __ ] for  you your mommy and daddy didn't fight it  out i still see parents really  interested in like fighting it out for  their kids it makes people incapable of  working [ __ ] out i think kids need to  fight out their own fights we've  demonized losing kids watch parents  fight coaches and teachers on behalf of  their kids when they're faced with  adversity but i do feel a lot of 18 to  25 right now struggle because they were  put in a cocoon that really  demonized losing in a world where  repetition of it really does lead to  happiness